another day I'm to be able to do it all
there we call it when you go in the
bumhole huh Black Widow that's not what
you call it yeah so you ever heard yeah
once you do it with your iron man maybe
if you have like a serious Marvel
roleplay fetter and then when you
spiderweb on her face she whips out her
she'll oh yeah DeRoos as that Sam that
sounds very Marvel tastic
what's up dudes I'm Ryan right I am
Jerry I'm Andrew so today we're gonna
check out Captain America Civil War
official trailer number two now if only
the thumbnail of the trailer didn't give
away the big surprise of passage even
though we knew he was gonna be in it
already or all of Facebook today yeah
we're gonna watch this right now then
we're gonna talk about it and despite
showing the special appearance in the
thumbnail I am still super jacked to see
him in the trailer yeah of course I
forgot something did you figure that now
okay nobody look
ah all right cool all right guys yeah
sexy time job try to save as many people
as we can
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
but you don't give up give up never
surrender York Washington DC
chuckle yeah okay that's enough captain
people are afraid
that's why I'm here we need be put in
check
whatever form that takes I'm game I'm
sorry Tony if I see a situation pointed
South I can't ignore it
sometimes I wish I could sometimes I
want to punch you in your perfect teeth
I don't wanna
oh sweet at the safest hands are still
out
I was wrong about you the whole world
was wrong about you
come on word is the O bleeding birth
I'm not the one that needs to watch
their back
it doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
you just started a war
I'll stay down final or have you do this
all day
all right I've run out of patience
underoos hey everyone hey dude hi
everyone
I hate those kids they're reacting yeah
they're excited dude we got everyone
together for this room they're fans of
the channel but I hate them you know
pure hate I've been having a pretty
shitty past two days it was refreshing
to watch this trailer and to feel like I
have something really big to look
forward to in May the early reviews of
this like from test screenings are seen
they was reported that this was Marvel's
best test screening they've ever had and
it's also the longest film they've ever
had it doesn't feel like an Avengers
movie you know like I thought it I was
worried it might have that kind of vibe
because of the fact that it's like all
the Avengers are Muslim number in here
but it still feels like a totally
different kind of film which I really
like yeah it just feels like the Marvel
Universe movie to me I like the tone
that it said in this trailer because we
understand both sides you know like from
cat's side we understand he's not going
to trust any more government agencies
after what just happened in Winter
Soldier then from Iron Man's side we see
that he's you know after what happened
in ultra age of Ultron he feels
completely responsible for the almost
the destruction of the world so now he
feels they need to be in check you know
it makes it makes total sense on both
sides you know you you have an
understanding of each side's motivation
why they're going to war against each
other it's interesting you know with
like Batman V Superman coming out how
they're acknowledging the destruction of
everything that happened in Man of Steel
in Metropolis this movie's doing a
similar thing with going hey you guys
really saved the world but look how much
you guys also help [ __ ] up cities damage
all yeah yeah and people still die yeah
yeah and like I like Tony's perspective
on the situation like no we still need
to exist we but I need to get this under
control yeah the bring in general Ross
back you know gives us that reconnection
to Incredible Hulk
I love the callback that also - I loved
when cap says I can do this all day
that's a callback to the first of two
Captain America the First Avenger when
using
beat up by the bullet he said the guy I
can do this all day and then when he's
fighting the Red Skull at the end of
that film he says the same thing I can
do this all day so I love the call back
in there no one's gonna say it when do I
say I can do this all day all day when
I'm penetrating the [ __ ] I really like
what they're showing with Black Panther
you know like this movie so far the
trailers really showing off the
characters and their superpowers I want
to see like how they're gonna portray
Black Panther underneath the suit
because he's a really interesting
character there's a he's a prince
there's a lot to that guy he has like a
[ __ ] ton of powers yeah and he's a
prince you know that Wakanda yeah that's
uh in Oregon yes exactly and they show
us clearly that Rhodey guys I don't know
about no it is 100% yeah we're not
knocked out they're not just trying to
get the audience to think does Rhodey
die and we got to find out because we're
so invested in Rhodey see actually
seeing those two shots in this trailer
makes me less certain he's gonna die
where's like if they only left is that
one clip in the first trailer Hill Road
II like I actually did pick him to die
before I could even saw this trailer -
actually isn't it interesting how this
all starts because cap wants to protect
his longtime friend Bucky and then it
seems like Iron Man gets pissed when his
best friend gets shot down ha they're
not that different they're not that
different he understands that typing it
seems like the whole theme of this movie
is friendship
yeah for sure [ __ ] caressing Whovian
all pso2 again I'm speculating here just
from everything we saw in Winter Soldier
when they were speaking to the computer
um I forgot his name's Justice gave me
right now but he told them that Black
Widow was saying that a you know
shielded when Hydra invaded shield that
they would have been stopped and then
they showed a picture of Howard Stark
and I said accidents will happen well
who does high percent to kill the people
on an important job they send the winter
soldiers I believe that the Winter
Soldier they sent him to kill you know
Howard and Howard Stark and Tony's
mother and that's also a reason why you
know Tony wants revenge on or
they're you know wants to do you get the
Winter Soldier it's the man who killed
his parents
I'm always speculating that from what I
saw in Winter Soldier so he says like
this doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
and then Tony gives him that look of
like oh yes it does and it's also back
with a lot of depression this doesn't
have to end in a fight yes it does
so I remember daddy jr. present remember
when he squeals like a little girl in
the traumatic bitchslaps
Captain America damn mother [ __ ] and
then cap goes spinning control that's
the most powerful bitch-slap I've ever
seen yeah we look pretty business
Laughlin is it a slap there's like a
punch it's like I can't get punch yeah
but it looks like it's from a different
take though because his mask is down now
and then Tony's like you just started a
war I feel like this is gonna be the
most epic Ironman we've ever gotten like
someone who's really like taking charge
being a full front leader yeah that's
gonna have like the badass lines and
everything you know this trailer has
this sort of like oh holy [ __ ] this is
gonna be a showdown vibe you know yeah
like they got that right with this where
I'm like well what happens when there's
a rift in the Avengers and they have to
face off against each other yeah I feel
like that fight scene with Black Panther
and Bucky on that rooftop is gonna be a
very memorable fight I hope so like I
hope it's like really coolly marshal
Artie choreographed II you know yeah
yeah that good I know but I want it like
Winter Soldier up the ante when it came
to like a martial arts fight over they
do with in very tacky yeah a very
efficient martial or he's a martial
artist and I feel like we're gonna get a
cool fight scene with that especially
because he had the claw no aim by far my
favorite MCU movies I'm closest Captain
America the Winter Soldier one of the
main reasons is the hand-to-hand combat
as you just mentioned in that film
bought it stands out way over in the
other ones an issue when I saw that when
I saw the TV spot I was like okay how
the hell can they possibly be the Iron
Man's team especially because visions on
the team
and then people were reminding me that
Scott because I'm not I made it clear I
don't really read the comics but I watch
all the movies they were telling iCarly
which is someone who's gonna be like the
most supreme powerful one yeah
and it's cool to see that they're
evolving her character in this you know
from we introduced her an age of Ultron
and now we're even taking her character
to a much bigger level it's interesting
to see how these how they still make
these films so strongly intertwined she
can conflic with your mind and vision is
all the mine yeah it's it's a cool
counterpoint and also too in the comics
they're actually or they were married in
the comics so I love how also an age of
Ultron he's the one who saves Scarlet
Witch and then in this trailer she's the
one who's putting him down so I just I
find that very interesting the one who
saved her is the one she's like using a
spell on basically a man is more than
just cap and Iron Man everybody got a
dog in this fight yow doesn't it look
like visions asking for a [ __ ] no it
is his way I was like it looks like if
if we're going to entertain that
scenario looks like he's asking for the
reverse that situation that he wants to
blow her yeah cuz he was looking yeah
cuz he's on the ground I thought he was
like kneeling like here I want to be on
my knees I guess this is how I
envisioned it's a [ __ ] happening it's
a further leerin logic the sequence with
um ant-man was cool what's he playing
through Iron Man tam yeah he flew
through Iron Man Sam he's such a lovable
character and also too he's a huge fan
boy of Captain American you could tell
that an ant-man like how excited he got
when he was uh when he was with Falcon
like I was playing The Avengers like
he's a big fan of this I'm very curious
like you to see that dynamic but I have
a feeling it's gonna work as again Paul
Rudd is very likable his character in a
man is he's very likable and I really
can see him infusing into caps team I
think when it comes to ant-man and
Iron Man like fighting that's a fight I
had been hoping for ever since dr. Hank
Pym in an ant-man movie was comparing
the suit to the Iron Man suit and saying
how that like the Iron Man suits a piece
of crap and so it's gonna be cool to see
like the atman soon go up against the
Iron Man see they show crossbones that
was pretty sick yeah as crossbones in
the comic books spoiler alert he kills
Captain America but then Captain America
comes back in the comics so he didn't
really kill him but anyways oh yeah well
that's in the comic Civil War so okay I
don't know how you can go a whole video
without talking about Spidey here this
suit looks really interesting I feel
like they lessened a lot of the lines
and stuff and like I mean they like
enlarged everything for you colors and
less blood like the black and even the
spider logo is smaller yeah yeah you
notice the eyes it actually looks a lot
like Deadpool and it actually moves like
they like it's his eyes actually moved
like you'll see if you keep watching the
shot it really was a callback to
Deadpool and also in Deadpool there's a
few Peter Parker references in there you
know they say he says go get him tiger
and then also it says Parker Avenue
Parker Street and that scene with
spider-man clever job on the marketing
by the way because the thumbnail makes
you think he might be on Captain
America's Team I really just want that
to be the last they show yeah I don't
please no more I already done two on
swagger man in the trailer yes but I was
okay with it when I was watching it yeah
that's about as far as I think you guys
should take it leave it at that it also
reminds me of vision in age of Ultron
when they showed him in the trailer at
while watching it I was like in fanboy
heaven I was still happy to see him but
I didn't I don't I didn't want to
actually see it until I saw the film we
knew we were gonna get spider-man this
film and again I'm cool with what they
showed right here but that's I'm good
right there he's definitely asking for a
[ __ ] better
nothing tastes like a burger is asking
for a bad [ __ ] because we're new to
the channel you can subscribe today and
become a reject reasons to Jerry and
dank ass Stubbs exists on this channel
it's Jerry's playlist it's like his mini
channel inside of the real rejects and
Joo Koon does not have a last name you
twitter.com slash egg or 7-eleven movie
source channel and YouTube does movie
reviews and all that shiznit follow us
on our social networks Instagram Twitter
Facebook you know I love what when I
trailer drops
everyone asked me to like pretty much
drop everything I'm doing mm-hmm and
just do it and they think it takes two
minutes when in reality it takes
anywhere from three to four hours to put
a full video together uploaded
so sorry you don't get your free content
yeah earlier just remember you don't
have to pay for it these were spend time
to consume it